beyonce has twice as many reasons to
celebrate every year on june 13th
because it's her twins roomie and sir's
birthday
to mark the twins fourth birthday the
superstar shared a sweet message to her
website
writing quote what's better than one
gift
two happy birthday roomie and sir
is this the biggest thing you've ever
done becoming a mom this is my
greatest greatest accomplishment and
i am the happiest i've ever been and i
feel
the most empowered i don't care if i
won awards or you know i don't care if i
made good money whatever
this makes me feel strong and this makes
me
feel so lucky to be a woman the grammy
winner welcomed the twins in 2017 with
husband jay-z
the couple also has a nine-year-old
daughter blue ivy
during a 2019 interview with elle
beyonce sheds some light on motherhood
and its challenges she explained quote
i think the most stressful thing for me
is balancing work and life
making sure i am present for my kids
dropping blue off at school
taking roomie and sir to their
activities making time for date nights
with my husband
and being home in time to have dinner
with my family all while running a
company
can be challenging
[Music]
and in a rare interview published in
april by the sunday times
jay-z gave a glimpse into the couple's
parenting style
sharing that the most important thing is
to show their kids love
he explains quote feeling loved is the
most important thing a child needs you
know
not here's this business that i'm gonna
hand over to you that i'm creating for
you
[Music]
baby greatest creation was you
jay also adds that despite creating an
empire
he'll never push their kids to follow in
his footsteps
quote what if my child doesn't want to
be in music or sports
i have no idea right but as long as your
child feels supported
and feels loved i think anything is
possible
everything that i pray for god's gift i
wish i would have prayed more what's in
store for roomie and sirs careers may
still be up in the air
but when it comes to blue it seems the
talented youngster is fated for a career
in hollywood
[Music]
that's blue singing brown skin girl a
song on her mom's visual album blackest
king
the collaboration earned blue a b-e-t
award
in naacp award and her very first grammy
i never tried it for anybody else
singing
a grammy winner at nine years old blue
is already on the fast track to success
a precedent set by her mom who achieved
a milestone at the 2021 grammy awards
earning the most wins ever after nabbing
a trophy for savage remix
with fellow houston native megan the
stallion who praised beyonce's big honor
while speaking with e.t
beyonce is a treasure to everybody in
houston
pretty sure to everybody in the world
but specifically from where we're from
we just love
absolutely love beyonce she set a record
tonight how important was that too
it's very important uh as just a black
woman entertainer
uh black women in general um we're here
we're here to stay we're here to take
over we've been doing that
but like just shout out to beyonce for
making her story tonight